madame la Présidente panneau pour le
groupe la France
insoumise madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre nos pensées se
tournent à cette heure vers le Proche
Orient où les peuples Israéliens et
Palestiniens souffr encore une fois je
souhaite depuis cette assemblée exprimer
une pensée emplie d'humanité pour les
otages les civils tués en Israël par les
actes de terreur perpétrés par le Hamas
ainsi que pour les civils qui à Gaza
sont tués sous les bombes de Tsahal nous
condamnons tous ces crimes de
guerre un seul message doit parvenir du
concert des nations en cette heure si
grave une heure qui n'est en rien
propice aux polémiques
franco-fançaise un seul message doit
parvenir du concert des nations cesser
le feu c'est un message qui nous vient
du Secrétaire général des Nations unies
du pape ou de Loula qui préside le
Conseil de sécurité des Nations unies
cessez le feu car le pire est à prévoir
quand le ministre de la Défense
israélien assiège Gaza privant 2
millions de civil d'eau d'électricité et
de nourriture violation du droit
international face auquel la France ne
peut rester
silencieuse nous n'avons jamais eu
autant besoin du courage de la paix que
dans ces moments cela fait trop
longtemps que la communauté
internationale a laissé la situation
sans
venimer de communiqués du communiqué du
président de la République pas un appel
au cesser le feu pas une fois le mot
paix notre pays rond avec la tradition
diplomatique qui est la notre Proche
Orient depuis 65 ans il nous faut œuvrer
au rétablissement d'un processus de paix
qui mène à deux états sans quoi les
horreurs passées s'amplifieront non
seulement des atrocités présentes mais
aussi des désastres à venir aucune paix
durable ne peut voir le jour sans
respect du droit international et sans
mettre fin à la colonisation
ame la prre
ministrerou la VO indépendante toujé la
France de char de
GA la voix de la France qui quand elle
parle éc la voix de la France qui fait
entendre la parole de la paix et ne
s'aligne pas sur les positions V guerre
d'un gouvernement d'extrême droite la
voix de la
franceffirme que tout
[Applaudissements]
les la langue de la
paix